[Applause]
thank you thank you for showing up so
early so I'm going to talk about I guess
learning in games but the main focus
will be in a game that's not stable
enough and I guess that's what dynamic
population stands for that is the
population exchanging underneath and I
guess for connection to the team of this
year and the theme of the workshop if
you participate in such a game you're
going to have to observe that something
changed and learn from it so at least
the information feedback model I'm
thinking of learning will become
necessary feature that people have to do
as they participate so I guess maybe the
prime game I want to think about is
traffic routing similar things apply to
online advertising for the very same
reason online advertising is yet another
thing where you participate over and
over again here in the traffic right in
case I guess maybe best to think of the
Rattlers as the players and the Rattler
certainly are routing packets over and
over again as time goes for this talk
and that's actually not necessary for
the results and maybe I can say a little
bit more about how general the results
are going to focus on congestion games
so a congestion game is one where the
cost depends on how many other people
are using the same edge or same know the
same pass or how much the congestion is
on a particular link but again the focus
is is that traffic streams are changing
as time goes on so there will be game
repeats but sometimes the certain
traffic streams are certain you know you
downloading some data from a website and
you're done reading the New York Times
in the morning now you no longer
downloading them on you either switch to
something else or someone else
downloading something else or whatever
else is happening something that maybe
not explicitly written on the slide but
will be necessary for anything I can
tell you is that the speed at which
these changes are happening of course is
a bit slower quite a bit slower than the
speed at which repeats occur you know if
every single second there's a whole
different set of things going on then
learning is maybe not the right attitude
here
but given that my assumption is that the
learning that you stay in the system
somewhat long enough so you can you have
a chance of figuring out what's going on
so repeated game will be a very simple
model discretized time every iteration
you know people take some action and
something happens and then next
iteration and something else happens
there I'm going to assume that the
objective function of the player is
average delay or average performance so
summing up performance over time in the
case of packets I guess maybe a slightly
better objective which maybe one can
adopt some of these things to allow
allowing packets to get dropped but
average delay is at least a standard
summarizing objective function here and
I guess the main assumption and I guess
the main connection for the team that we
have been pursuing here this workshop
and this semester is that I assuming the
players want to take the input from the
previous runs and what they experienced
in the first few times and one who
learned from that data
I guess there's two reasonable questions
that I guess what should I ask what can
one say about the outcome that is maybe
better phrased
if the people stay long enough in the
system then they have a chance to learn
and then hopefully I can say positive
thinks about that this sort of learning
without any central coordination will
lead to reasonable social outcome if
they don't stay in the system long
enough this is kind of hopeless so maybe
one quantitative way of phrasing how
stable has to be the system or how
stable has to be one participant for the
good things to start happening just
based on learning with that central
coordination so
there's a large community including me
you've been thinking about quality of
outcomes in selfish in in surface
situation and maybe my odd result is one
of my favorites for sure is trying to
compare Nash equilibrium business
socially designed optimum and maybe one
classical result of this form is about
traffic writing it says that and a cost
of a Nash equilibrium cost here is
complete so total delay is no worse than
the cost of optimally writing twice the
delay I guess this is sort of where I'm
coming from as a basic result but please
note that this is a one-shot game with a
von Schaack Nash equilibrium and what I
want to do is repeat the game and
actually not the same game or more
precisely yes the same game but not the
same participants so but the notion that
I'm borrowing here is this price of
energy which is how I'm going to measure
how good the outcome is cost of Nash
equilibrium divided by cost of the
optimum so if you're visiting you know
thirty percent up from the optimum as a
theoretician I'm going to view that as
reasonably good compared to if our end
players your factor enough from the
optimum that's going to be you that's
horrendously bad I hope you agree on the
horrendously bad and I hope you agree
that compared to that the good thing is
reasonably good there have been a
beautiful set of literature by many
other people I guess traffic writing
style games and actually the kind of
games I'm not talking about but today
but the results are applied to a lots
and lots of action games so different
action setups they all prove in this
price of energy balance in the small
constants some of them to which I still
viewers are some what's more constant
come back at the end of how one can try
to make these things better but that's
not the focus of my my talk today my
talk today actually the focus of lifting
this to this sort of dynamic repeated
game so what's the dynamic repeated game
and this is mostly based on I guess in
the beginning
a bunch of co-authors whose work it's
based on but large part is based on
total Icarus and Vasily sacani suspect
whose pictures you can see up there and
I'll have pictures of the others as they
results come up so the model we wanna
use is we play one game and to make it
concrete let's think about traffic
writing game but if you want to if you
prefer options then it's an auction game
where people are bidding in the options
every iteration each player has some
small probability P at which he decides
that he's done I'm going to keep this
problem this is a randomized event that
is take probabilities here but then he's
going to be if if he vanishes he gets
replaced by averse case other guy now
what does it mean that he gets replaced
by averse case other guy won one hand
even if I keep this probability very
very small like you know one over the
number of the size of the population so
for M players one in n that means every
iteration is something they change or in
general if it's probability P then with
an players P to the P times n players
get replace and expectation something
changes to give away the punchline and
you'll be able to keep this probability
pretty damn small pretty damn actually
big the change over pretty big but
something of the not quite as you know
one in log N or something but still
close to a constant fraction of the
population gets replaced so there is a
significant change happening in the
population every single iteration
because it's the population changes all
the time there's definitely need to
adjust and I'm not feeding any
information to them in particular notice
that the replacement is verse kids and I
feeding no information to them so they
don't have to learn from their own
experience in the game that way they
made something happy appear to change
like you know I kept to always driving
on this road there was no one here but
the last couple days it has been
horrendous I better try exploring
something else yeah
so you're assuming that the size of the
population stays the same you just yeah
I that's an excellent question to ask I
admit I'm a little bit cheating here in
yes I'm do making the assumption that
our sue made for I think literally just
for mathematical simplicity that the
pilot size of population states and all
the time so if someone lives it gets
replaced I yeah we probably should
improve it extend it to two you know the
replacement is probabilistic also accept
the the properties of the new guy is
worst case good questions thank you okay
so first let me actually tell you a
little bit about what happens in
learning and what's known or what
standard in learning in repeated games
so the classic learning you know when we
repeat the game is actually a really
really old question and they may be
first or the first that I know a person
who really started to think about it was
Julia Robinson in 51 which I admit was a
long time ago the question she asked is
one particular learning and I guess I
this is her cause fictitious play which
you simply pretend or pretend to believe
that the opponents are randomly sampling
from the distribution they're not
adjusting to the game and you think of
the play as as random sample four-day
behavior and just best respond to that
one that's called fictitious play and
that's what Julia Robinson studied and I
guess maybe not as much from the focus
on her results so I have it on the next
slide but the question she asked she was
thinking of this as a pre play as a way
to find the Nash equilibria and that
prevailed for a long time in history in
fact there are two of these reputable
results out there
Julia Robinson's result that's on
two-person zero-sum games it actually
does happen that two-person zero-sum
games fictitious play does converge to
Nash equilibrium and extended result on
and even sort of more specialized
version two percent not
Samba two-by-two we all have two
strategies that too as the property but
this is about it after this this does
not converge to and that the Nash
equilibria prepay is a reasonable thing
to do if you do if you playing a game
sort of like the incentive action that
is the spectrum action that just
happened in the US where there was a one
really important one big event in life
and they did actually do pre tenth place
of this form to try to help to help the
participants learn how to bid in it and
then I was the real action this is the
framework she was thinking about I'm in
contrast thinking about the framework
where auctions happen all the time there
isn't one big action but auctions happen
all the time like at auction or like
traffic routing it's not like we think
about it for a day and then in the
evening Virat or the packets instead we
ratting them all the time and there's no
distinction between the real and the
learning but instead of warning them or
expecting them to converge to Nash
equilibrium I just hope that they learn
something and hopefully they better off
when they learned so I guess the notion
of learning that's very helpful here or
what I will use is something called no
regret learning which I guess from a
[Music]
national equilibrium like without the
assumption that they reach some sort of
Nash equilibrium and this is what Nash
equilibrium would would like so the
assumption would be that they somehow
varied a cost they do at least as well
as a single single hindsight or at least
not much worse if they do a little bit
worse that's called regret two defenses
for this notion which maybe all of you
are very familiar with so I'm not going
to spend a lot of time on so what this
means in plain English that if there's a
really good solution acts sooner or
later they wake up to it how much later
is the error and that they're very
simple and natural algorithms that can
push the arrow down to roughly rooty
marriages usually cornering that
algorithm
where no regret here means regret going
to growing less fast than the time or
going to zero relatively it's also known
that if you repeat the very same game
there no regret learning will converge
to something called correlated
equilibrium and maybe the notion of
correlated equilibrium will make you
feel more the connection to Nash
equilibrium it's a distributed so Nash
equilibrium is a distribution where
different players independently choose
actions and then something happens
correlated equilibria is literally the
same thing I just took out the word
independently that is a distribution
where the correlated Li from a joint
distribution productions and the very
same rule applies no one wants to
deviate to a different action so long
term play converges to correlated
equilibria oh man just to get you a
sense if you didn't of course it's the
past history that we correlating on we
can correlate not because there's a
correlation device but instead because
we all learning from the very same
history so that's sort of in a single
game learning in a single game fashion
before I move to what I really want to
talk about is this dynamically changing
population I want to actually slightly
change what I mean by this no regret I
want to change to a bit more permissive
version of no regret and I guess this
was suggested by recent paper of ours
with Dylan Foster Karthik cetera and
also to Doris licorice
oops sorry this new picture should be
backwards this meant to be alphabetized
and I messed up alphabetic order sitting
here sorry which is a bit more
permissive version of no regret learning
where I allow you a multiplicative 1
plus epsilon error that is if you're
going to take an hour driving to work
then let me assume that 5 minutes plus
and minus is not going to be what you're
optimizing on that there is a error a
fixed error
think of it say 5% 10% that this is the
error that you willing to tolerate the
reason I really like this version two
reasons sorry
like this version first of all the
additive once I give you a percentage
multiplicative error the additive
regular great error goes really really
small that is the dependence of time
goes away that's just the number of
options or decide dimension of the
option space is what matters and the
time doesn't matter anymore it's a
constant learning error after that you
can keep up with this error and the
second reason I like it because having
looked at auction data this seems to
prevail match over people doing this
actual no regret doesn't they don't
appear to humans automates learning
algorithms don't appear to optimize the
to the last percentage this is a quiz
actually a pretty big epsilon like five
or ten percent matches data reasonably
well if you go push the epsilon lower
it's that's matching it so I should talk
about this offline of it even extend to
that notion I always saw that there is a
historically ignoring that algorithms
people think of the error as an additive
error and actually if you go back to
your very first algorithm of this kind
you ever heard this is how it starts and
then they choose the epsilon to optimize
this expression and I guess looking at
data
it does seem and admit that's auction
data it does seem like that's not
happening people are picking a fixed
absolutely not optimizing the epsilon
because at the end they don't care about
the percentage and I think that's really
not like this is a sort of an attitude
difference value do you care to tune
your learning great well enough or seems
like people don't care and not as much a
difference between the discounting like
do they really do the utter optimization
to adjust to the data or in your
learning rate or you not do that
I guess here is a bunch of datasets that
I did look at where the suggestion came
from that this is a maybe a good notion
and I guess interestingly if you look at
the set of papers here so this is the
data set I looked at that's Microsoft
advertisement auction the rest of them
are all actually human subject
experiments and interestingly two of
them
the Nissan North II and the friedenberg
paper actually making up from the
opposite point saying that the agents
aren't learning but if you look at the
data then learning actually matches this
is not the approximate laureate learning
matches the date of pretty well actually
the most interesting paper from our
source question is the federal burg
paper up here where they main conclusion
is people are very heavily recency
biased which of course if you do if you
do learning with a discount discounts
them then this this is the right
learning so I come I come I'm happy to
come back and maybe offline too but this
is somehow the most relevant paper to
your question because they doing a they
claiming that discounting matches better
the behavior than learning okay so again
but I said this price of energy was
originally introduced by could sue
Pearson Papadimitriou and I said the
cost versus cost of Nash versus the cost
of the optimum actually there have been
a beautiful sequence of papers taking
Norah great learning in a fixed game I
don't know if that like very identical
players identical game which extends the
price of energy notion to two learning
outcomes here is what they do they say
the cost of Nash equilibrium never paid
capital t iteration and the sum over the
T iteration it's a fixed game so the
optimum never changes so divided by T
times the optimum that's the average
ratio and they take those results and
extend it to
this sort of learning-dot-com I think
the stream of papers was originally
studied by this other implement company
paper in Oh 8 there's couple precursors
and then there's a very general
beautiful favorite by tim roughgarden
which I'll come back to in a second
and what i want to talk about is
extending this to where underlying the
population to change to so what i'm we
have in mind instead of my price of
energy is the same cost as cost goes to
cost of overtime but is that not the
optimum is changing also so i divide by
the sum of the Optimum's as they
happened i think this is a reasonable
objective function i hope you accept it
clearly i can't possibly hope given my
data feedback model that every single
one of these ratios was at the sam
states law if something changes in a
population it will take the players a
couple iterations to make up to this
fact
so all I'm coming on average they do it
okay yeah societal optimum in a game
it's not clear to me but the player
optimize it's a societal optimum optimum
over social welfare some of other
players average delay of like I guess
what's in me delay is average delay of
all the players as it happened an
average delay of all the players had me
try to optimize that quantity some of
the players the the social cost is the
sum of all the costs I'm not averaging
any place I something but that's
mathematically equivalent that make
sense I guess this is actually part of
the places where my cheat came in that I
kept the population fixed because
otherwise I should keep averaging and
then I'm dividing everyone's experience
with a different number depending on the
population size it definitely is very
convenient that I have the same
population I don't have to worry about
that
okay so that's the mall that's the
version I want to think about and to
tell you but maybe what monkey I want to
think about there but I want to tell you
about I have to go back to this theme
paper and tell you a little bit of how
this price of energy bands were proven
actually for this talk maybe only
keeping sort of one major message which
I think at least for our purposes is the
major message here what Tim did in
developing this framework that says that
price of energy results extends to
learning outcomes in a fixed game is to
observe that almost all or virtually all
price of energy results go in a very
very simple frame a simple framework
which he called smoothness framework and
this is what they do there he says okay
there is one thing we know about the
optic the Nash equilibrium and that's
this inequality here if it is a Nash
equilibrium this thing I want to think
about why doesn't the player do what the
socially designed optimum wants him to
do why the hell isn't he switching to
what I as as designer know is optimum
let's call that AI star that's what the
optimum would be and I know he's not
reaching because apparently it's not
good for him that's the sin equality so
he currently has cost I and this would
be the cost if he switched and
apparently he's better off and this is
in a very simple proof this is all I
want to be able to use this one in
authority and he says that apparently
many games are proof comes down to an
inequality of this form which I'll come
interpret in a second taking this sum of
the player costs in this funny deviating
everyone single-handedly deviating to
the optimum and comparing it to the
optimum now when I first told this in a
class I actually started the price of
energy segment of my class with this and
I got the advice from the students
that's why I of course you made up some
inequality just exactly so that you can
prove the price of energy in
it's almost designed like that once you
have this you add the Unicoi to your
head that's the cost of some of the cost
of players what you got here is the cost
of the strategy and you just rearrange
and get the price of every band and this
is precisely or the proofs go so my
students were right this is precisely
designed for the right thing the more my
point is almost all the proofs follow
this framework this is how the proofs go
to help you interpret this in case you
haven't been as used to it as I have I
guess what this inequality really says
that if the cost of your current
solution is extremely high compared to
the optimum if this in this inequality
despite me being below von and lambda
being above 1 this is the dominant term
because the cost is super mu / high then
apparently someone can improve or
average they can improve someone can
improve clearly that means it's not Nash
someone the deviator side the beauty of
this inequality is that this
automatically lived - learning outcome
in a fixed game and here is her in a
learning game again going to my
approximate version we get some sort of
inequality not about and individually
that individually they like the what
they did better but at least compared to
this optimum and remember go back only
at what I care about how they care about
the optimum so they don't regret not
switching to that fixing called the
optimum again combining this dinner
quality you get something by rearranging
the terms one maybe interesting thing to
notice here other than the epsilon
showed up because I put up an epsilon is
the form of this regret the term coming
from the regretted or and I guess that's
the point of this the the one of the
points or one of the interesting points
of switching to this epsilon version is
that the speed at which they converging
to that to this outcome is now very fast
that they rather than 1 over root the
kind of speed at convergence they have a
1 over T style convergence so they
converging to the socially good outcome
in a super fast way which going to be
handy once I start changing the
population okay so this is all about v
game remember
Bhuvana mainly focus on non fixed games
that is games when the population is
changing as we go and again but I want
to assume is they learning from data now
I have to actually start thinking about
what do I mean by learning from data so
again remember driving or remember
router gets pink gets feedback that no
no that packet never went through or
that took forever to go through how do
you learn from data are no regret notion
said this and again I like the epsilon
so your cost over time is no worse than
low bit worse than a single fixed going
to this hindsight now you can think
about this as there was in our proof
what we have in mind this will be the
optimal solution and with changing
populations there is no such thing as
the optimal solution or you can think
about it this is really not a good idea
the whole point of learning is that you
should learn to adjust to the situation
and learning you know learning is better
than Nash equilibria precisely because
if you react to what's happening in the
world this is not expressing that fact
it says that you know if there's a fixed
good thing you notice it so I want to
actually change the notion of learning a
little bit and maybe that's the moment
I'm coming back to our Sue's question
instead of no regret learning which I
need so just to drive home the point
that you need this fixed are the jimmies
hindsight is very weak so here is a
repeated game this red guy is the person
I'm thinking of when he shows up it
turns out there's a lot of traffic in
this upper pass he chooses the lower
pass and he you know whatever he's happy
and then for whatever reason those guys
vanish and so those packets vanish but
instead these guys show up and said well
I'm having a bad experience here lots of
congestion I need to switch
he needs to adopt this is exactly what
he wanted tomorrow
that players do adapt to the to the
population okay so this is from the
literally it's necessary perspective
here is the the the proof perspective I
showed you the proof of how we proved
this price of energy bands so what would
I need to adopt my proof to the price of
energy band I would need something like
this I would need a proof of this that
the cost that they experiencing
comparison as to the optimum cost and if
I had this I would be home same proof
and what is this the only thing changed
that the optimum is now a fragile object
it's it indexed also by by the iteration
camp of course maybe you'll realize that
this is just no way it's not even
hopeful to adjust to this how can you
possibly learn if I'm changing the
optimum on you every single time you are
the question I was thinking of different
bid options and I guess I guess I'm
losing of traffic wrapping so a player
does not change his source destination
pair during the game you still live
where you live and you work where you
work and if you change you your your
workplace that's actually a change event
like now you're not the same person or
not the same traffic pattern for an
auction version I guess you can think of
it as a as a different mapping
and again yes there is not necessarily
optimal for you that's optimal for
social welfare there's not clear you
want to do this the social designer
wants you to do this because it's good
for social welfare this is what I would
want but this is really not hopeful that
people can learn this well and maybe
naturally of course unfortunately one
thing you would hope is that this isn't
such a fragile object this optimum here
but the optimal is actually a very
fragile object so maybe in this audience
that doesn't need to be driven home but
even if I run a sort of matching game
and have a matching optimal one guy
leaves and a matching changes are
literally everyone we change on a
ginormous Atlantic bus so that you know
the optimum itself is a very fragile
object so let's start from the other
side how about can I learn and I guess
going back to this epsilon regret paper
we actually did work out for the same
reason of working on impact on this
project however can you learn and this
is something that actually very same
algorithms almost take care of a little
bit of a of silver I mean me to do it a
little bit discounting actually this
time the scanning the past that is
putting in a bit of recency bias so
taking the very standard learning
algorithms and heating them because this
a slight recency bias is a discounting
the past with a bomb plus epsilon 1 plus
Delta rate and this is the kind of
things they do it says that if you wanna
learn instead of a fixed X with
hindsight you want to learn well enough
for a changing X design side of course
the more exchanges the hopeless more
hopeless it gets but if X will only
change K times I guess you regret our
view in our case we'll go in linearly
with K that is in a fixed epsilon
observer K is the way I'm multiplying
the regret error that is but some of
interesting facts about is I don't need
to know how often we change of course
I'm not getting warned that the system
that system changed so if you were think
of this as I'm your warn you every time
the
system changes this isn't surprising and
because these key changes the system
consists of key phases each of which you
get this error but the point is that I'm
capable or we can do this or the same
algorithms take care of this even if you
do not want when the change happened and
you don't even know how many there will
be so your algorithm runs in a fixed
Epsilon it cannot adjust the number of
changes because you don't know very
natural algorithms take care of this
sort of changing error so as long as I
can keep the changes low people will
learn well enough compared to that in a
no regret learning algorithm so at the
very high level this is where we get to
sort of at the theme of what I did with
that the mathematical details if the
game is part of this price of energy
that's proven with the smoothness
property so the game has the smoothness
property and I've heard to be able to
generate a close to optimal not really
truly optimal but close to optimal
solution that's very stable doesn't
change very often and the papers people
do this recency bias learning then I can
keep the price of energy in this even in
this changing environment goes to the
price of energy of the optimal solution
and I guess just to remind you that
instead of giving you the details of
these theorems which is coming in a
second I gave you the outline of the
proof the proof but the proof did
instead of using the true optimum I use
a this table approximate optimum in my
pro system I want to I assume that they
doing the sum no regrets recency bias no
regret learning of the kind that
generates this epsilon over K times K
over epsilon sort of regret or if they
do do that then they the same price of
energy will prove will adjust making it
a bit more concrete here is a sort of
summary of
nicest sinks we can say and again this
is I guess works on on traffic reacting
games and a number of different games so
if I have a price of energy proof for a
game that's along the smoothness
framework that outline which is almost
all of them then I can keep a roughly
one in log and population size change
the law came from the regretted or
remember there was a log be regretted or
which I have to make Cove a so I have to
keep people in long enough that they
cost dominates the error that the error
is not the main part here and the
inordinate learners then I guess a price
of an American proof comes in three
different parameters and if I work if I
take generous view of what the game is
then all parameters can can be made to
go to one so their product of three
different things alpha is the price of
energy and I just copied the price of
energy proves not because of our results
but because of some other work by Vasily
and some of his co-authors that that I
think is nice to put here if you make
the lie the game larger and larger in
population they have beautiful results
that says the price of energy goes to
fun that is you know if you're doing a
racking game the more people are around
the less price of energy you have which
is a nice observation to make there is a
separate for single called gamma which
is the regret error I Optimizely the one
over p1 over Logan I just went to the
edge when the regulator or doesn't
dominate the last then of course I'm
losing a factor of two because I have
half half error half of course if I'm
willing to P go faster than faster to
zero than Ted then of course that error
goes to 0 also and a third part which I
maybe will spend one more slide at the
end is the last to the optimum I need
not the true optimum which might be very
fragile but instead I need stable
optimum where the particular people spy
it's not changing as the game changes
and there also we can show the
as the changeover is get going to zero
stability can go to one that is the loss
of you can get this table optimum
without actually losing and so let me
spend two more slides at the end is
trying to talk about this last item the
stable optimum part so what does it mean
that the optimum is stable so maybe the
simplest thing is you if you're really
totally willing to change your
optimization algorithm you're not
getting the true optimum and then one
it's so simple I think in two slides I
can at least convince you that the a
there might be something in here so if I
change this is a very simple example
again back to matching and remember
matching was very sensitive because you
do a whole augmenting path every time
someone leaves if I want a stable
optimum then here is something I could
do how bad I changed my optimization and
do it a greedy algorithm the greedy
algorithm here I lost a factor of two so
this is not going to work it's a literal
loss of factor of two and before I do
the greedy algorithm I also do some
rounding don't take those values so
seriously do it within one plus a parts
of one plus Epsilon lost another one
plus epsilon if I do both of those I
claim it will get very stable now what
did I do here it's I created a ton some
tone so ties in the greedy algorithm and
as literally the the sequence comes on I
can resolve tries to keep stability in
mind that is if you have a night ever
you have an edge I'll keep you if there
are other people tying with you whatever
you have priority that keeps it very
much much much more stable enough stable
to get all of our results for a higher
version higher level version and very
converging to one comes from is a
different notion of differential privacy
which is really the last thing I want to
tell you maybe many of you heard about
differential privacy in a very very
different context differential privacy
as the name suggests is something about
privacy was championed by the work at
all but the particular notion on games
I'm using
is a current paper which is much more
recent it says that we doing some sort
of game like traffic ratting and you
want it to be that the central router
via rat you in a way that gives you no
information about who asses in the game
he wants to keep your information give
you a solution of course you know your
solution but your information is private
in front of everyone else
what does private mean in English really
it doesn't matter to them whether you're
there or not that's precisely what I
also wanted our notion of stability is
very very almost identical to the notion
of privacy and in fact one and managers
have over them that if I take many of
these papers they usually struggle like
crazy to make they are they sync
algorithmic that is they can prove that
such a private solution exists but of
course it's the designer wants to hand
you those parts you have to make it
algorithmic I don't need this this
notion is in my proof it's not in an
algorithm I don't care whether it's
algorithmic as long as it exists I'm
okay so I'm a little bit better off than
they are but I guess it's a very simple
general result I guess because I kept
the general think so
the theorem statement so abstract maybe
I end with a particular definition and
this is a matching version and I guess
in the matching using using using the
greedy algorithm we get a factor of four
or four times four plus Epsilon lost
compared to the optimum and we get that
at a very high turnover rate and I'm
going to stop here and thank you for
your attention
and hopefully some of the things like I
guess the world message I want to take
away
I want you to take away is this may be
the top line here on this slide we have
been or I and number of us seeing a
price of energy have been talking about
learning in games and the game theory
community I've been doing that since the
50s so even longer than then we were but
somehow the
that learning is good because it can
adjust the data and learning in games as
an outcome there were somehow not
connected as a single salt and clearly
learning is good because they can adjust
to data and we should think about what
does it mean in a game that learning has
this property so let's say someone's
giving you information so many people
are driving everyone is adjusting
solution
you're suggesting is that I can change
my stability notion I guess maybe kind
of the way Arturo is suggesting as a
function of the input you got maybe it
seems like it I need two sinks you like
if I think of a strategy is a function
of your outside input then I guess every
single will just carry over you're right
it's a good point I do have to like one
awkward sink that does anyone needs to
sink through of what might be a good
application here is that in a traffic
rat thing I do know about the dimension
of the spaces like in a you know it's a
number of edges because that's the
dimension like you have exponential many
paths but the dimension of your
selection space is the number of edges
if I think of my strategy space as a
function from advise server they were
announced something to the to my choice
that lifts the dimension of the strategy
space and that log the error suddenly
might be actually a big error I need to
think through what exactly happened
there I have to keep I don't have to
keep the strategy space low but I do
have to keep the dimension of the study
space low otherwise exploration takes
takes a long time yes you had a question
I mean I did actually I so good point so
yes originally was defined by - no
regret learners with no Epsilon and you
can just adopt the epsilon and you know
some extra extra epsilon show up and I
did have this on my slide and I found
fast enough to page back when I adopted
to learning I automatically put the
epsilon same so you're losing a little
bit so you know the band was lambda over
from 1 minus mu actually the only
dangerous part is that the MU gets
multiplied by the one minus epsilon
email to make
that didn't go to zero so epsilon has to
be small enough that it doesn't wipe out
that part but yes
okay I suspect this breaks thank ya this
is so there are two versions here if I
want to keep my version with the epsilon
then yes because and I kind of you know
a very simple argument even if I tell
you where the changes occur there is
already an on lower bound on the log and
look the over epsilon and even if I tell
you that now everything's changed this
is the moment please adopt k times
epsilon this is all you can hope one
interesting thing that we cannot do and
I don't have a lower bound proving that
I cannot do it in the different regime
and people picking the best epsilon if I
were to know what K is
I can optimize this and pick the best
epsilon and it ends up with a root K
kind of error I don't know how to do
that without knowing K because you're
not observing K you know you don't
actually know whether it's a cost high
or is it that camus big so but I don't
have a lower band that I can't somehow
job tonight
epsilon a better way to get to that so
the open question here is can I get down
to the root K error that this classical
way of getting down the error to root K
would be to take this formula and
optimize for epsilon which I can't do
because I don't know what K is
that's open but the R is the epsilon
version it's it's right
we start at 10:45